>> WITH ONE MONTHS AGO BEFORE
THE MIDTERMS THAT GOP HAND BRIN
HOME THAT YOUR SAFETY IS IN
PERIL WITH DEMOCRATS MPOWER.
MURDER RATES JUMPED MORE THAN 4
PERCENT LAST YEAR, THAT
DOESN'T FACTOR IN SOME OF THE
LARGEST DEMOCRATIC CITIES LIKE
NEW YORK, LOS ANGELES,
PHILADELPHIA, EVEN THOUGH
DEMOCRAT POLICIES ARE TO BLAME
PRESIDENT IS TRYING TO PIN THAT
ON.
THE DEPUTY PRESS SECRETARY
TELLING FOX COME UP INHERITED
RISING VIOLENT CRIME RATES.
JUDGE, IT IS REPUBLICANS FAULT,
THEY DIDN'T GIVE ENOUGH MONEY T
BIDEN'S AGENDA.
>> THAT IS SO INFURIATING.
YOU JUST HAVE TO AT THIS POINT,
IT'S A QUESTION OF FAITH.
YOU EITHER BELIEVE HIM OR YOU
DON'T.
WHAT HE'S REFERRING TO WITH THE
REPUBLICANS VOTING AGAINST
FUNDING THE POLICE OUT IT WAS A
SLUSH FUND THAT WASN'T INCLUDED
IN THEIR LEGISLATION FOR THE
PANDEMIC OR YOU COULD USE FUNDS
FOR CERTAIN THINGS BUT THERE WA
NO REQUIREMENT IN THERE WAS NO
RESTRICTION.
IT WAS THE DEMS THAT REQUIRED I
DURING THE SUMMER OF 2020 AS
BUSINESSES WERE GETTING BURNED,
PEOPLE WERE GETTING KILLED IN
PRECINCTS BURN DOWN, IT WAS THE
DEMOCRATS YELLING DEFUND THE
POLICE.
IT IS AT DEMOCRAT CITIES WHERE
THE MEARS CONTROL THE POLICE
DEPARTMENTS WHERE WE'VE LET THE
BIGGEST PROBLEMS IN THIS COUNTR
AND THE FACT THAT YOU'VE GOT NE
YORK, LOS ANGELES, CHICAGO,
PHILADELPHIA, IT WON'T EVEN GIV
THEIR NUMBER OF CRIMES TO THE
FBI TELLS ME THAT THAT INCREASE
IN MURDERS OF FOUR-POINT TO
PERCENT IS PROBABLY DOUBLE WHAT
THEY'RE SAYING IT IS.
IT IS A SHELL GAME WHERE THEY'R
JUST A NO, WE NEVER SAID THAT,
YOU SAID THAT.
COULD GET THE PULLING IS
TERRIBLE FOR THE DEMOCRATS ON
CRIME.
>> I WAS SURPRISED WHEN I SAW
THAT THAT ABORTION, INFLATION,
IMMIGRATION, ALL OUR TAKING
BACKSEATS TO CRIME.
PEOPLE REALLY FEEL THAT MAIN JO
OF GOVERNMENT IS TO KEEP PEOPLE
SAFE AND TO MAKE THEM FEEL SAFE
LIKE YOU SAY.
YOU KNOW, IT IS, PEOPLE HAVE TO
HAVE A SENSE OF WELL-BEING THAT
SOCIETY IS GOING TO TAKE CARE O
YOU.
THAT THE CRIMINALS WILL BE
SUPPRESSED AND APPREHENDED AND
PROSECUTED.
WHEN THAT STARTS FALLING APART,
IT'S CONCERNING TO ME.
I HATE WHAT DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE
TWO CUPS FREIGHT I HAVE SO MANY
COP FRIENDS IN TO SEE HOW THEY
FEEL AND HOW BELEAGUERED THEY
FEEL, SAILED BY DEMOCRATS
BREAKING THE ONLY OTHER THING I
COULD SAY JOE BIDEN TALK ABOUT
WITH CRIME IS TOO TIRED TO TO
GUNS.
HIS TICKET THEY ARE SAYING
REPUBLICANS DON'T WANT TO VOTE
FOR THE ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN, AN
THAT IS WHAT HE'S FOR, BUT THEY
DON'T WANT THAT.
THEY WANT TO KEEP THERE AR 15'S.
THIS GUY, PHILIP FROM, TO YOU
KNOW HIM AT THE WASHINGTON POST?
THIS GUY IS SUCH A KNUCKLEHEAD,
HE WRITES THIS CRIME IS SURGING
IN FOX NEWS COVERAGE.
HE TRIED TO CONFRONT A BUNCH OF
DEMOCRATS AND ASK ABOUT THE
CRISIS, THIS GUY COMES OUT AND
WRITES THIS WHOLE PIECE IN THE
POST THERE IS NO CRIME CRISIS H
IS SAYING VERY TEA SAYING IT'S
JUST ANECDOTAL.
FOX IS JUST THROWING UP A BUNCH
OF VIDEOS.
THE CRIME RATE IS NOT UP, CRIME
RATE IS DOWN, AND IT'S NOT A
MAJOR ISSUE.
THERE'S ALL THESE MAJOR ISSUES
THAT ARE MORE IMPORTANT THAN
CRIME.
IT IS A TOP THREE ISSUE IN EVER
SINGLE I DARE HIM TO COME ON MY
SHOW.
I DARE YOU.
>> COME ON, PHILIP RADKE HE IS
LIAR TO.
HE WON'T BE ABLE TO DEFEND THIS
COLUMN.
>> BUT IF YOU LOOK AT DEMOCRAT
CANDIDATES LOOK AT FEDERMAN IN
PENNSYLVANIA HE WANTS TO LET GO
OF A THIRD OF INMATES GO TO NEW
HAMPSHIRE AND YOU LOOK AT RON
JOHNSON'S OPPONENT.
HE IS TRYING TO GLORIFY
CRIMINALS AS WELL.
YOU WILL LOOK AT AT AMOXIL IN
NEVADA.
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT ENDORSE THE
INCUMBENT BEFORE AND NOW THEY'V
ENDORSED HIM.
GO TALK TO ANY LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER ON THE STREETS, AND THE
WILL TELL YOU EXACTLY WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CRIME WAVE,
IT IS NOT REPUBLICANS.
ITS BIDEN AND IT'S EVERY ONE OF
THOSE DEMOCR